[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est très important et pour le
paramètres il y a environ de la
transports en commun et on aimerait bien
si vous venez un jour voir dans le métro
ou dans le bus avec nous
c'est vraiment cool mais alors vous
m'avez raté ce matin c'est dommage
j'étais gare du Nord et vous étiez pas
là bah oui c'est bête ça c'est
bêtements et bien
très bien
[Musique]
ensuite c'est toujours très difficile de
commencer une compétition il y a
toujours une vraie appréhension et on a
pu le voir parce qu'il y a énormément de
surprises finalement dans cette
compétition on a vu l'Argentine
l'Allemagne la viande perdre face au
Japon on a vu oui oui